did you see end game yet yeah oh yeah
what was it about there's a [ __ ]
jewels and [ __ ] and everyone's like what
the [ __ ] are all the goddamn Jewels
that's actually true [ __ ] yeah you're
right that's exactly what the movie's
about
[Music]
okay so this is the careful boys
reacting to the Marvel's Galaxy uh
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 trailer
if they have King in the trailer I'm
gonna be like again we were gone
quite a while yeah what happened come on
this side Ryan to me what happens next
foreign
[Applause]
I missed that one you know what second
one no I think I did I forgot
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ]
it's fun don't forget
[Applause]
where we came from
we have been running
our whole lives
Pete I'm done running Skies
[Applause]
good
fly away together
one last time oh you see Groot where the
baby one no he's growing Buffs and [ __ ]
is that an otter
oh is this guy brother
oh yeah
yeah he was a baby on the last one this
is really cool dude they do a really
good job on these ones
we will kill anyone who gets in our way
no not kill anyone kill us he'll know
people kill one guy one stupid guy who
no one loves you
is James gun still doing this yes yeah
yeah dude James got no these are all
right he's so good
he's really good the best [ __ ] is that
he is in charge of all the DC movies I
know
dude he did Suicide Squad it was a movie
was so good it's funny how canceling
just didn't work it didn't work no
because that was [ __ ] canceling yeah
they try to cancel him for what and then
and then um Disney dropped them for a
second what did he tweet they fired him
yeah they full-on fired him yeah what
did he do it was like the people it was
like jokes like bits about like
you know stuff with kids it was it was
definitely like joke wait but wasn't it
a video that he made like ages ago and
then it was like a skit oh when someone
throws a baby or something yeah it was
like a skit or some [ __ ] I think that
was you guys no ours was a dog was that
a South Park yeah exactly [ __ ] like that
it's like what what what happened what
happened oh so Ryan's just showing me um
the tweets that he posted you can read
it this one's pretty funny read one of
Anthony's tweets this tweet's from this
tweet's from June June 30 2008 he said I
burnt my tongue on an enchilada [ __ ]
Mexicans
yeah that's [ __ ] funny dude yeah it
doesn't mean any harm by it no he hates
Mexico yeah yeah
I never know
to Twitter to deliver the news
and most of these are retweets it's not
even him yeah it was wild anyway did you
guys watch
um well first of all what'd you think of
the trailer I don't I don't know what
what it's about but it looks good well
that's good isn't it that's good but
sometimes I kind of want to give it away
but sometimes I want to know what it's
about at least but that's that's how the
second the trailer for the second one
was two the trailer for Segment didn't
reveal what that one was about it it
didn't reveal that he was going to meet
his dad or something no no I don't know
maybe they did maybe they did oh did
they I didn't even know I don't remember
because teasers are different and
trailers are different and then oh right
and then once the movie comes out and
it's been like been out for a week and
they do different tricks oh true true
yeah but also what I always really like
about the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
are the soundtracks the soundtracks are
really good so already I'll suck you in
yeah this one's great music already and
they should face the music was pretty
good also also this one showed that
showed Gamora but this that's 2000
um not the recent one it was after end
game that they went back found the 2012
gamer who came with Thanos so I'm
guessing that one stuck with the
Guardians remember though she like kicks
him in the nuts and stuff she might be
doing her own [ __ ] in this one maybe you
know all the stuff did you know that
Anthony Lee huh yeah it's after infinity
wars did you see end game yet yeah
oh yeah what was it about there's a
[ __ ] jewels and [ __ ] and everyone's
like what the [ __ ] are all the goddamn
Jewels that's actually true [ __ ] yeah
you're right that's exactly what the
movie's about I think he watched end
game like five times because of taika
okay
they spliced Turco from Breaking Bad
battling Thanos no wait
it's so funny and it's like they do it
so perfectly and how he beats Thanos he
crushes the [ __ ] Infinity Stones and
he snorts it and he's like whoa
and he kicks his [ __ ] ass and it is
so good dude it's so good
that actor is so good he's so good he
was in um oh God clearing present danger
with Harrison Ford he was the sniper in
it yeah and he's the guy who's like
whose fault is it in Harrison Ford's
like it's my fault I don't remember I
didn't know I didn't remember that he
was in that street aren't they coming
out with another spin-off of Breaking
Bad [ __ ] or is it actually another one
Walter Jr's life aren't they I think
it's like a Breaking Bad something a
pre-course I didn't realize Jesse
Pinkman was on The Office
he showed up did you guys oh yeah yeah
so he shows up to the office he's like
all like [ __ ] sketched out and [ __ ]
he's like he's crazy that's Jesse pink
man yeah especially he's like his Creed
here oh that was like an Oscar yeah yeah
oh and he was he's like oh you have the
package that he gives it to somebody
else all right guys it's got my math
everybody and I was like oh it's so cool
I love when seeing like like the world's
collection was it a gag it was like the
gold word yeah something like that
and of course he's just trying to hit up
Creed that's like the gag they did where
they filmed uh they did a Malcolm in the
Middle thing did you see that oh they
got the
um the main actress from the mom from
Malcolm middle they got her to film a
thing with uh Brian Cranston where where
he wakes up and he's like I had a dream
that I was a meth dealer
that's just so good
yeah and like he he like just goes oh
what the [ __ ] is that and then it pans
and it shows his Heisenberg hat on the
couch oh yeah so Mr Lee they brought
back Gamora I'm less
um updated on the on the Marvels but
they brought back Gamora after and
during so during Ending game Gamora
comes back yeah no so basically an end
game right they have to go to three um
with a Bart's mom's time traveler friend
yeah
yeah in order to figure out where the
Infinity Stones are so one of the times
they have to go back uh is when uh what
surface the sister uh ends up going to
the [ __ ] one planet and then she has
that thing which like she freaks out and
has a seizure and [ __ ] like that and
it's because her other sisters on that
planet right right and it's like whoa
it's like you're here from the future
and then Thanos is like oh maybe I blah
blah blah right that Gamora who's still
alive who hasn't been thrown by Thanos
into the [ __ ] truck
that's right that Gamora comes back she
was Chuck fights in the war and then
ends up I guess by way of this trailer
hitching around and sticking with the
guardian got it so that's why I'm like
okay cool like they they keep well
unless unless this is also throwing us
off and this is a different time zone or
some [ __ ] like that that we don't know
about so watching this trailer do you
think that they will be friends forever
Gamora and Chris Pratt no like the whole
team the crew the Guardians the
Guardians for ever nah I feel like that
like there's gonna be something that
maybe even don't they have to though
they're they're the Guardians they're
like the buds I don't know this one
seems more climactic seems like
something's ending right and is James
Gunn gonna come direct another Marvel
movie being the head of DC that's the
other question I have that's what I'm
saying like what's gonna happen are they
gonna conclude some [ __ ] are they gonna
kill my boy Rocket Raccoon or some [ __ ]
they better not dude or because they
kind of made it seem like oh he's
dipping out yeah I'm tired of running
yeah and then in the screen you see like
him hugging an otter
maybe that's his love maybe that's the
love of his life maybe he's like hey I'm
at the game y'all I found my home I'm
out yeah but kicking with my other
that's like when you see two people and
you're like why do they like each other
that's weird but then it's like oh I
shouldn't judge this one yeah yeah like
it makes sense raccoon and otters they
can be together yeah that's cool I will
say Rocket's [ __ ] dope he's the best
yeah he's honestly my favorite the best
gags him in group they have the best
bags together yeah I only like baby
group none of that [ __ ] old group
dude you don't like teenage group that
means that means it's working [ __ ] that
means that they they made a proper
teenage character who's annoying plus
they had that what is that one kid uh
play in the role I say kid because he
was in that one [ __ ] he's a silver
guy Silver Surfers no the silver guy
right you talking about silver face
silver is this face silver and it's the
autistic One Quicksilver no not
Quicksilver no no um no but um he
[ __ ] he's in that uh Maze Runner
movie you know what I'm talking about
that actor Timothy Timothy no not too
many the guy who's in the the trailer
right now there was one
I don't know what the actor's name is
let me look it up this is why kids you
don't do hallucinogens okay
[Music]